And everybody, welcome to another Zoom call, where I'm not feeling so well, so this is going to be fairly short. We only have about five questions that came in.
So I apologize for my voice today, but feel free to chat at any questions.
Always a reminder to look at the announcements on the homepage of the member site.
Alright, first question. If I start a new supplement or Ivermectin, how long does it take to see a difference?
Well, if you're talking about cancer, how long does it take to see a difference?
Unfortunately, it can take months before you see a difference on a change in supplement regimen.
So, don't be discouraged if you don't see a difference in a couple weeks.
But if you don't see a difference in three months when the cancer is still growing, or your numbers are going the wrong way still in three months, then we need to change things.
But if, let's say you started on a supplement two weeks ago that had blood work done and there wasn't anything improved.
In fact, things were worse than, you know, we don't know yet.
So it takes some time for things to change, so just going to be aware of that.
Next question. What rife program could you use for chronic nerve syndrome?
So, chronic nerve syndrome is a type of neuropathy, and so that's what I would think to use neuropathy.
I would also use inflammation.
The inflammation program may help more than anything.
I would also think of anti-inflammatory nutrients as well.
And I would look at if there's anything that you're doing dietary wise that may be causing inflammation, like different foods that you might be eating that you could have a sensitivity to that is causing inflammation.
That would be my go-to thing would be those things.
You could definitely run the neuropathy type programs as well.
That might help if you don't go to a car proctor think about going to a car proctor to get things checked out.
Because it depends on what it's related to.
Whatever you're diagnosed with something that says syndrome, it means that it's basically a collection of symptoms that may have multiple different causes.
So getting to a cause would be the thing to do.
So, I don't think we've spoken, the person who wrote this question, I don't think we've ever spoken about this.
So, if you want to have a conversation about this and we can get into some more details about the history of this or you and possible causes, I'd gladly do that as well.
But you always, whatever you're dealing with anything, you want to see if you can figure out what the cause of it is.
Next question, could you provide some information on dietary and supplements or gout management?
Well, gout and gouty arthritis is an inflammatory arthritis is what that is.
And it's usually flared by a diet that may be high in purines.
So you could google high purine foods or you probably could google a gout friendly diet or gout natural gout diet.
But foods that have a lot of purines, foods that are sugary, alcohol is the worst thing for gout.
I don't see a lot of people with gout when I practiced years ago, I used to see a number of people with gout and they were always people that were beer drinkers.
So, it was very difficult to get them to stop drinking beer because usually people that are chronic beer drinkers are, you know, alcoholics cause an alcoholics that can't stop drinking that.
But other foods can cause it too, so you can be, you know, not an alcoholic consumer, but you might be addicted to sugar.
That is a big driver of gout.
Foods that have high purines are like organ meats, red meat, which is so good for cancer patients, especially if you have anemia.
So it's tough if you have cancer and anemia and you're trying to eat more red meat to build up your red blood cells, but you also have gout.
So, that's a difficult thing.
As far as supplements that historically have been good for gout, cherry juice, and there's capsules of tart cherry capsules that a person could take.
You can drink tart cherry juice. It's very, it's very tart by its very name.
But that has helped people with gout.
Lemon juice with water could help people with gout. Coffee could even help with gout.
But then just making sure you're following the seven phases of detox because a lot of people with gout tend to be constipated, have issues with detoxing.
So even though they're not drinking alcohol, they're not eating a ton of hearing foods and things.
There's not detoxing very well. So think of those kinds of things.
One of the potential many side effects of my chemotherapy treatment has been brittle bones. Seems to be true in my case.
I've had two very minor falls with a last beam about four months ago and I broke four ribs each time. Oh my goodness, I'm so sorry.
Although I am much better, they still haven't really healed as evident by the CT scans.
Ribs are really hard to heal fractured ribs because they're always in motion. Every time you take a breath, you're into hostile muscles, contract.
And it's very difficult for a bone to heal when it's constantly being tugged on.
Would you recommend supplement wise or diet wise? That might be helpful for healing and strengthening bones.
Also, my wife has similar questions pertaining to age related osteoporosis.
Okay, the only supplement that I recommend now for bone destruction due to the testesis.
Bone healing due to a fracture, bone healing due to osteoporosis is the one supplement called osteo-K.
osteo-K. Let me see if I can pull it up here really quick.
osteo-K.
The reason why is that there's just been more research. You know, the old thought was, oh, we just need to take more calcium.
Oh no, well, that didn't work. So we need to take more calcium with vitamin D.
Well, okay, well, that didn't work. Well, what we do, we need to, you know, we need to take, you know, other complementary nutrients.
Well, none of them are really working to build bone. This is the osteo-K right here.
It's on our website and taking four of those a day.
The secret of this is that it has this certain type of K2, vitamin K2, that's called MK4.
If you look at most of your vitamin D supplements, I'll say vitamin D plus K2, right?
But almost all those, that form of K2 is in the form of MK7, which is great.
MK7 is great to help you absorb vitamin D.
But MK4 is the necessary vitamin K component to get calcium into the bone.
And it's, it's just not in any supplements, and you need to have this dose.
So three a day gives you 22,500 micrograms of vitamin K2 in the form of MK4.
And if you don't get MK4, you're never going to get calcium into the bone.
Your body will convert some MK7 to MK4. So if you are taking it or getting it in your food, you'll get a little teeny bit, but nothing like this dose.
And it's going to be harder to heal your bones.
So this is three capsules a day. I said four capsules a day, but I'd say three to four capsules a day.
If you're trying to heal bones, you could go up to maybe five, but I wouldn't go more than that.
You don't need any more 500 milligrams of calcium.
Getting any more calcium to this without getting MK4 is actually at a risk, because if you get more calcium without the MK4,
then this is just, calcium is just circulated in your blood, and it has the potentiality of blocking your blood vessels.
It has a potentiality of binding to cholesterol in your, in your walls of your arteries.
So you have to have MK4. So the history of women take, oh, you have osteoporosis need to be on 1500 milligrams of calcium,
was just the most horrific advice given to man because all these women in their heart,
remember women's heart disease in the 1970s was like one fifth that of men's heart disease,
and now it's almost equal. Well, it's because of the use of calcium without using MK4.
So you need to use calcium, but at a lower dose, never 1500 milligrams, never.
And you have to be taking MK4 at this kind of dose, and I have not found any other supplement that has,
there's not another one on the market that I found that has this except this company.
That's not even all that expensive, it's have any bucks.
So that's the only way to go for osteoporosis, bone loss, try to build bone strength and prevent bone loss.
Now, if you don't have any history of osteoporosis, or you just have been told that you have osteopaedia,
or you don't have any history of bone metastasis, then you only need to take one of these a day.
So, but this is what to take.
I'm finding that on one of my longer nights in my life treatment, I have to interrupt my last hour.
So I assume you're waking up and you're like, oh, I'm going to get up and get going here,
and there's still an hour left in my program.
What is the acceptable amount of time to put pause before returning back to it?
I mean, if you are getting up on one of the nights and pausing it and coming back to it,
there's no harm in doing that no matter what the time is.
But do you have to?
No, you don't have to.
Remember, there's frequencies in there that are constantly recycling.
That's how I write the programs because you really shouldn't be running frequencies more than three minutes,
180 seconds at any given time with some exceptions.
You go up to six minutes or so, but you so they have to recycle.
So you add up how many frequencies can you run in an eight hour program or running several hundred frequencies,
but even several hundred frequencies, they're recycling.
Otherwise, we would only have a four hour program.
So you're getting those again.
So if you are, if somebody's got, you know, let's say eight and a half hour programs and they ask me,
well, I only literally, only sleep five and a half hours every night.
I have to go to, you know, I've had a trucker that did that.
He has to go to work.
He's only weeks, five and a half hours.
So that I shortened his program.
But by all means, if you're, if you're missing an hour or an hour and a half every, every couple,
every few days or a few of the programs and, you know, that's fine.
So you're, you're going to find.
And if you are pausing it, coming back to it, then you're not missing anything.
So I apologize, Rex, where you just jumped out and this is going to be a short call because I didn't have everybody questions.
And I'm, my voice is failing quickly.
But feel free to chat in any questions. That was the last one.
Are there any programs on the right that should not be used
while healing from cancer?
Everybody's ever asked me that before.
Oh, no, I don't think so.
I mean, the only thing that I would say is that, you know, let's say,
let's say you're dealing with the throws of cancer.
And the cancer is very active and growing.
I would spend most of my time running my cancer program.
And not worry about my cold morbidities.
However, it can be true that my cold morbidities can be, you know,
affecting my ability to get better from cancer.
So you just kind of got to balance that out and, you know,
and see what's the most important thing for you.
I want you to be ready to a program for, I don't know, you know,
your glaucoma and, you know, have you not be ready?
You're cancer programs or something like that.
But so just have a balance in that.
But there's nothing that you can't run.
So, insertively different infections and things like that can bring
a person down who has cancer.
So you want to run the infectious programs.
If you got the crud like I have right now,
running the pneumonia blaster and the cold and flu programs
and the different influenza programs might be a wise thing to do.
So you just, you got to try to use your best sense of that.
But there isn't anything that you should not use while trying to heal cancer.
No, there would be anything harmful in any way.
Any other questions?
What's it?
Don't be shy.
Okay.
Well, I wish you guys the best today.
And, um, hopefully, you're all state healthy.
And we cherish your prayers.
We're also in our family as well.
God bless everybody.
All right.
Bye-bye.